hey 42 here take a look back through
history and you'll find no shortage of
famous figures who blur the boundaries
between facts and fiction
think Leonard is the first of Sparta or
King Midas both were 100 real but it's
safe to say many of the stories
surrounding them probably weren't
most of these Titans of Times Gone by
only Rose to True World Fame after their
Tales were corrupted and endlessly
embellished long after their deaths
every once in a while someone emerges
from the haze of History whose dazzling
Deeds are so inexplicable they become
Legends within their own lifetime
the subject of today's video is one such
man and his story is quite simply one of
the most unbelievable I've ever shared
on this channel it's hard to know where
to begin really so how about some
highlights he was born a peasant but
Rose to control the whole of Russia he
had the power to heal the sick and the
best doctors of his time couldn't
explain how he did it he survived
multiple assassination attempts
including being poisoned stabbed and
shot
he had the power of Prophecy and made
several bold predictions that
subsequently came true he slept with
thousands of women despite never bathing
he brought down a 300 year old Royal
Dynasty almost single-handedly and most
importantly of all his pickled penis is
preserved in a Russian Museum to this
day
this is the larger than life story of
Gregory Rasputin or as I like to call
him the magical sex wizard who brought
down the Russian monarchy
[Music]
foreign
and I wish I could sit down every
morning for a lengthy breakfast but by
9am my mind is usually totally consumed
by whatever project I'm currently
working on for the channel before I know
it it's 11 A.M and I'm so hungry I grab
an unhealthy snack well that bad habit
is no more since I turned to fuel hot
and savory for me huel is a
nutritionally complete meal that I can
make in minutes it fills me up it has
everything a human needs to function and
most importantly it doesn't interrupt my
workflow I've been absolutely loving the
huel hot and savory range with hot and
savory I can prepare a quick convenient
plant-based meal packed of 26 essential
vitamins and minerals and 24 grams of
protein it's made of entirely natural
ingredients and most importantly it
tastes amazing perfect for a rapid but
healthy lunch or dinner fuel contains no
tricks it's not a fat diet it's just a
no-fuss way to add some plant-based food
into your life did I mention it's also
really affordable so click the link in
the description to try huel today if you
use my special link you'll be supporting
the channel and you'll also get a free
heel shaker bottle so don't miss out
thanks to huel for sponsoring this video
Rasputin's story is one of the most
outlandish ever told but his Beginnings
about as humble as it gets he was born a
peasant in 1869 in the tiny Siberian
Village of pokrosky
he had seven siblings but only Rasputin
made it to adulthood very little is
known about those early years beyond the
fact that like most of his peers he
received little in the way of Education
it's likely he couldn't even read nor
write until adulthood and he was
regularly in trouble with the local
authorities thanks to a ponchon for
committing minor crimes and a major
appetite for hard drink and soft women
by 18 he was married and would soon
raise three children all of his own
so far so utterly boring at this point
in our story Rasputin's life wasn't all
too dissimilar to thousands of other
Russian men of the era but in 1897 at
the age of 28 he decided to take a
pilgrimage to the Saint Nicholas
Monastery at virkatoria it was a journey
that would dramatically alter both his
life and the course of Russian history
[Music]
it wasn't an especially religious man
prior to this pilgrimage and his reasons
for undertaking a 500-mile round trip in
the name of a God that he wasn't all
that well acquainted with are unknown
some sources claim it was an excuse to
make a swift exit from pokirovsky after
being caught stealing a horse but I say
that the heavy drinking wantonly
womanizing Rasputin took the pilgrimage
because lad's weekends hadn't been
invented yet whatever the truth when
Rasputin returned some months later he
was a man transformed by religious
fervor well I say transformed he's still
drank like a sailor and chased women
night and day he just did a lot more
praying in his downtime over the
following years he traveled Russia
extensively styling himself as a
Wandering holy man he also developed his
own unique brand of religion built on
the foundations of an outlawed Christian
sect known as the clists whose murky
practices were rumored to include
massages and self-flagellation not at
the same time for his part Rasputin
preached that sin could only be overcome
if it was first understood which
basically gave him free reign to do all
the fun stuff in life in the name of
theological research he also taught that
it was possible to get closer to God by
achieving a state of sexual exhaustion
preferably by having as much sex as
possible with Rasputin himself
bearing in mind that he was one of the
scariest looking individuals to ever
have lived and was famous for never
washing and therefore smelled like a
Badger's [ __ ] you might be surprised
to learn that somehow this strange
strategy for seducing women actually
worked
Rasputin soon gathered a large number of
followers and there were growing
Whispers that during his time in the
Siberian Wilderness he developed certain
abilities
some say he could read minds others that
he could heal the sick with the touch of
his hand and all agreed that there was
something of a worldly about that man
by the early 1900s he'd caused enough of
a stir to attract the attention of
several important people in the Russian
Orthodox Church eventually those lofty
connections led him to Saint Petersburg
Rasputin's arrival in the then Russian
Capital was perfectly timed the city's
aristocracy were positively obsessed
with all things occult and Supernatural
so when the badger-centered Siberian
turned up amid rumors of magical powers
in 1905 armed with a soul-piercing stare
everyone wanted a piece of him
foreign
he received invitations from many of the
most influential and affluent families
in the city
Wrong by wrong he hauled himself up
Saint Petersburg teetering social ladder
until in November 1905 he reached the
final boss he was invited to meet SAR
Nicholas II emperor of all of Russia and
patriarch of the centuries-old Romanov
family and his wife Alexandra
theodorevna the Zarina
the encounter was planned for just a few
minutes but the self-proclaimed Mystic
worked his unique brand of black magic
on the monarchs and it was well over an
hour before he emerged from the palace
it's often said that people believe what
they want to believe and that no doubt
helped Rasputin win over the Russian
Royals you see the zarin's arvina were
absolutely desperate for the rumors
about Rasputin to be true because if he
really could heal the sick
that meant he had the power to save
their son Alexi who also happens to be
heir to the entire Russian Empire
you see Alexi suffered from hemophilia a
rare genetic disorder that prevents the
blood from clotting properly that might
sound like a fairly minor ailment but
sufferers live their entire lives on a
knife edge where even a small injury can
lead to devastating blood loss
hemophilia is a serious illness even
today but in 20th century Russia it was
essentially a death sentence the average
life expectancy being just first heat
Alexi was the youngest of five children
but since his Elder siblings were all
inconveniently female the line of
succession relied solely on his survival
in other words if Rasputin could keep
Alexi alive he wasn't just saving the
life of a treasured son
he was safeguarding the future of the
entire Romanov Dynasty
and it wouldn't be long before this holy
man was given a chance to put his magic
where his mouth was
as an interesting aside at the time
hemophilia was so common amongst
European royalty that it was often
referred to as the Royal disease
historians have subsequently traced a
rogue jeans back to a single patient
zero none other than the so-called
grandmother of Europe Queen Victoria she
was a carrier and her Offspring spread
hemophilia all around Europe's
aristocracy including the royal families
of Spain Germany and Russia Queen
Victoria was Alexi romanov's great
grandmother
anyway Rasputin was duly summoned to use
his magic powers on the boy and here's
where things start to get a little weird
it's easy to dismiss Rasputin as a fraud
a charismatic chancer who somehow
bluffed his way to the top but whatever
Hocus Pocus he implied on the Russian
air
to actually worked and not just once
Alexa's Chief physician would later
recall that whenever the boy was Ill
Rasputin would turn up at his bedside
spit and Alexi would recover in no time
in one of the more famous incidents the
prince suffered internal bleeding during
a bumpy carriage ride back from a
hunting trip before long he'd fallen so
Gravely ill that a priest was summoned
to perform his last rights and a hasty
telegram was penned announcing the boy's
death to the world
Rasputin was back home in Siberia at the
time and the desperate Sarina sent him a
telegram of her own asking him to pray
for her son despite being hundreds of
miles away Rasputin replied explaining
that God had personally assured him the
prince would live so long as no doctors
interfered in his recovery
I don't know about you but if I was a
fraudulent faith healer getting rid of
everyone with a modicum of medical
knowledge would be the last thing I'd do
yet the Sarina obliged and against all
common sense Alexi began to recover
almost immediately
even today more than 100 years later
nobody really knows exactly what
Rasputin was doing to improve Alexi's
Health it could be he was leveraging
knowledge of internal bleeding cases in
horses from his time in Siberia
while stoves believe his cures relied
solely on some form of hypnosis
still others put his miraculous healing
powers down to nothing more than simple
psychology
by dismissing the prince's Army of
doctors and calming his mother's frayed
nerves Rasputin May simply have created
a calmer quieter atmosphere more
conducive to recovery
add a powerful placebo effect into the
mix and who knows
if that's all a little vague for you
then don't worry I have a slightly more
concrete Theory aspirin was a ubiquitous
painkiller in Russia at the time and
would almost certainly have been
prescribed for Alexi but it turns out
that aspirin thins the blood and is
basically oral Kryptonite for
hemophiliacs
that little medical factoid wasn't known
to science until a good 50 years after
Rasputin's death
but it may be that by regularly
recommending Alexi's doctors be ignored
in favor of the healing powers of God's
grace
Rasputin was unwittingly protecting the
prince from the harmful effects of
ingesting aspirin
of course there's always the possibility
that Rasputin really had gained magical
healing powers by shagging his way
around Russia and refusing to bathe but
I'm going to go ahead and put that one
down as a long shot
ultimately it doesn't really matter how
he was doing it by ensuring blood flowed
through the prince's veins and more
importantly keeping it there whenever he
got so much as a Papercut Rasputin
gained the unshakable Loyalty of the
tsar and zarine
still Rasputin wasn't one to take
chances and so to truly seal his
position in the Royal household this
big-dicked Mystic made a prophecy
claiming that his Destiny was linked
with theirs and that if anything
untoward ever happens to him the house
of Romanov would fall
again it's easy to scuff it's such an
obvious ploy
except that prophecy would indeed later
come true
but let's not get ahead of ourselves
Tsar Nicholas II named Rasputin as His
official Lamplighter a role which saw
him look after the Royal household's
religious icons and gave him
unparalleled access to Russia's rulers
Rasputin made the most of this position
and before long he wasn't just healing
Prince Alexi he was advising on matters
of state and influencing foreign policy
but his elevated status had done nothing
to smooth Rasputin's rough manners nor
diminish any of his various at tights
rumors are bounded that the Mystic would
accept sexual favors and other bribes in
return for putting in a good word with
the tsar and his wife and when he
couldn't get what he wanted by abusing
his Newfound power
he simply took it by force Rasputin was
accused of rape on multiple occasions
including by the governor s who looked
after Alexi's older sisters but 20th
century Russia's version of the metoo
movement never really got off the ground
despite the weight of claims against him
including some from within the Royal
household itself Rasputin was
untouchable
the governor s was fired and his other
accusers simply ignored
even so a growing faction of religious
and political leaders were becoming
increasingly concerned about Rasputin's
influence in the palace several senior
members of the Russian Orthodox Church
openly denounced him as a heretic and
prime minister Peter stalpin tried to
get him exiled the Russian secret police
a precursor of the KGB opened an
investigation into Rasputin's conduct
which found amongst many other things
that he'd exposed himself in one of
Saint petersburg's best restaurants
in 1914 whilst visiting his wife who for
some reason hadn't divorced him yet
Rasputin was stabbed in the stomach by a
noseless peasant woman who believed him
to be the Antichrist
it was the kind of wounds that would
typically be fatal and yet after somehow
escaping his attacker on foot Rasputin
was left in a coma that nobody expected
him to wake from but he did and before
long he was back in the capital where
his power was about to reach its
pinnacle
just a few weeks before Rasputin's
near-death experience a little-known
Austrian Hungarian Royal was visited by
an assassin all of his own
that rolling question was known to his
buddies As Art Duke Franz Ferdinand and
unlike Rasputin he didn't survive the
hit
as you're no doubt aware Franz
ferdinand's death set off a chain of
events that culminated in the start of
the first world war in July 1914 Germany
declared war on Russia anzar Nicholas II
left Saint Petersburg to personally lead
his troops on the battlefields of Europe
leaving only his wife behind to run the
country
Alexander had always been more swayed by
Rasputin and without her husband around
she gave her mind entirely to the Mystic
within the space of 18 months she'd
appointed and dismissed no fewer than
four Prime Ministers five Ministers of
the interior and three Ministers of war
with rasputing guiding her hand at every
turn
it was soon an Open Secret on the
streets of Saint Petersburg that along
with accepting Rasputin's advice the
Sarina had also invited him into her bed
admittedly there isn't any hard evidence
that the affair ever happened but
considering how highly the Sarina
regarded Rasputin not to mention that
his religious ideology was to screw
every living thing in Russia it's
difficult not to believe the rumors
there's also the fact that renowned
scholar bony M famously sang Ra Ra
Rasputin lover of the Russian Queen and
if that isn't proof then I don't know
what is
regardless of whether or not they were
actually sleeping together Russia's
greatest love machine had clearly become
the true power behind the throne the
Worm tongue to Alexandra's Theodore but
every Worm tongue eventually meets his
gandal and in December 1916 a group of
noblemen decided it was time to Saddle
Up Shadow facts and go drive the demon
out
they were led by Prince Felix yusupov
husband of the SARS niece Grand Duke
Dimitri pavlovich the tsar's first
cousin and prominent politician Vladimir
pariskovic of course unlike Gandalf the
Gray none of these men actually had any
magical powers and so they were forced
to choose a more prosaic approach
to save Russia they were going to have
the murder Gregory Rasputin
he was invited to use the pubs Palace in
Saint Petersburg where he was taken to a
receiving group in the basement there he
was given tea and the plateau of small
cakes which all sounds very civil as far
as murders go except the cakes were
laced with cyanide
Rasputin was oblivious to the danger and
soon enough he was talking into the
poisonous pastries
but when he was finished rather than you
know dropping dead Rasputin merely asked
if yusupov had anything stronger than
tea to wash down the cakes
yusupa fetched some Madeira wine also
laced with cyanide but despite guzzling
free glasses Rasputin didn't develop so
much as a heartburn
to this day we still have absolutely no
idea how Rasputin ate enough cyanide to
kill an entire Village and survived
though in a very recent study rats were
fed both Cyanide and garlic and survived
turns out the sulfur content of garlic
can combat cyanide in the body
and every day Rasputin ate a frightening
amount of garlic anyway since the poison
had failed too well poison him yusupov
pulled out his pistol and shot Rasputin
squarely in the chest and that finally
seems to do the trick
Rasputin's body was stripped and one of
the co-conspirators drove to Rasputin's
house wearing the dead man's clothes to
make it look as though he'd returned
home as planned
next it was time to dispose of the
corpse that was yusupov's job but when
he went back down to the cellar
something rather unexpected happened
Rasputin stood up and punched him in the
face
yusupa fled the basement with a naked
and very much not dead Rasputin in Hot
Pursuit a naked man running is never a
pretty sight and the Bloody grizzled
Rasputin was no exception but all the
commotion brought use of Pub's friends
to the scene and more shots were fired
foreign
Rasputin was once more on the ground
this time with a bullet through his
forehead
safe to assume yusu pavenko were a
little rattled at this point so they
spent the next few minutes kicking the
crap out of the corpse just to make sure
it was really a corpse then they dumped
the body in a nearby Frozen River by way
of a fishing hole According to some
reports despite having been poisoned
twice shot multiple times and beaten to
a bloody pulp Rasputin was still moving
when he disappeared beneath the silent
black water
he was found the following day pressed
up against the underside of the ice as
though trying to break free his still
open eyes staring blankly up towards the
sky The Mad Monk was
dead meanwhile on the battlefields of
Europe things were going badly for the
Russians Nicholas II was turning out to
be an absolutely useless military
commander and a series of serious
tactical and logistical blunders saw his
troops lose battle after battle
the situation back home wasn't much
better either the country had been
crippled by the war effort there was
widespread hunger and discontent
confidence in the monarchy was as an
all-time low and despite trying to hang
on to power in 1917 the Tsar was forced
to abdicate when angry demonstrators
took over large sways of the capital
backed by members of the Russian Armed
Forces
the 300-year rule of the romanovs was at
an end
the Russian Revolution had begun
the tsar and his family were held on the
house arrest where they would remain for
about
it during which time the Bolsheviks led
by Vladimir Lenin seized control of the
Russian government
on the 17th of July 1980 Bolshevik
soldiers broke into a basement where the
romanats were being held and started
firing
they didn't stop until the former tsar
and Zarina and every single one of their
children were dead
at the start of this video I mentioned
that Rasputin was a man who blurred the
lines between myth and reality and there
are certainly many aspects of this tale
that stretch credulity certain elements
are widely accepted facts Rasputin
really did rise from nothing to have a
huge influence over the Russian monarchy
and he certainly played a large role in
its eventual downfall but others are
contested some historians believe
details of Rasputin's debaucherous
lifestyle were exaggerated in order to
discredit him and it's a fairly safe bet
that the events of his murder have been
spiced up a little bit oh and for those
of you still wondering when the hell I'm
going to get to Rasputin's penis don't
worry their weight is over the fate of
Rasputin's Pekka remains a surprisingly
Hot Topic even now according to one
story it was removed not long after his
death under orders from Grand Duchess
Tatiana daughter of the Tsar he was one
of the many women claimed to have been
raped by the Mystic
as of today you can find pickled penises
purported to belong to Rasputin in
multiple museums all over Russia
of course there is a slight logical
phallus e with that statement despite
his reputation as a lover of Epic
Proportions so far as I know God only
gave Rasputin one penis with which to do
his holy work over the years several of
the appendages have been tested to
determine their Providence at least one
turned out to be a sea cucumber and
another a 12-inch BM off of frankly
frightening proportions was found to
have belonged not to Rasputin but to a
poorly endowed horse
the truth is whilst it's still widely
reported that Rasputin's penis was
severed after his death like so many
things about his life this one's
probably just a myth we know for certain
that the offending appendage was still
attached during the autopsy and there's
no evidence it was later removed
by most accounts Grigori Rasputin was a
pretty terrible human being but his
story really is fascinating and if
nothing else it remains proof of
something many of us have suspected for
a long time
like you don't need to have good
personal hygiene to go far in life
thanks for watching